[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
narrowing down the jury in the death of
the ahmad arbury trial do you agree that
people of color
are not treated fairly in the criminal
justice system raise your hand if you
agree with that and bond denied for
south carolina attorney alec murdoch the
latest twist in the murdoch murder
mystery plus former president donald
trump adviser steve bannon could be held
in criminal contempt this as a former
president sues to keep personal files
under wraps and later convicted killer
derek shovin acquires a new attorney how
the ex-cop plans to move forward by
appealing his conviction law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin all eyes are on georgia now as
jury selection moves forward in the
death of a mod arbory trial
bottom line here is there is a
there is a case here in the superior
court that needs to be resolved and we
can't do that without jurors which means
we can't do that without you
so thanks
that's the message judge timothy
walmsley gave to potential jurors
tuesday morning as the second day of
jury selection kicked off before the
trial can begin 12 jurors must be seated
along with four alternates jury duty
notices were mailed to 1 000 people in
the brunswick georgia area with 600
people called to appear starting on
monday due to social distancing
potential jurors are waiting in a nearby
gymnasium and questioned in the
courtroom in groups of 20. all this as
three georgia men face charges of malice
murder felony murder and other charges
in the death of 25 year old ahmad aubry
in february 2020 aubry was shot and
killed while jogging near his brunswick
georgia home he was unarmed at the time
of his death father and son duo gregory
and travis mcmichael tailed aubry in a
pickup truck before travis mcmichael
shot and killed him the pair claimed
self-defense and planned to use a
georgia citizens arrest law that has
since been repealed and replaced the
mcmichael's neighbor william bryan
followed along in his truck capturing
the entire incident on his cell phone
the shooting created national outrage
after that cell phone video went viral
in may of last year after that gregory
and travis and michael were arrested
followed by brian's arrest two weeks
later all three men have pled not guilty
to the charges on tuesday law in crimes
network's linda kenny bodden spoke with
jason sheffield attorney to travis
mcmichael about finding a fair and
balanced jury
jury selection is the most important
part of any trial my belief is what are
you looking for in terms of a juror in
this case a fair juror
we're looking for people who understand
truly the concept of their duty and
their responsibility as a juror we're
looking for people who may recognize
that they've heard a lot about this case
that it's come from the media that it's
come from conversation in the community
but that they haven't actually heard the
true facts of the case
and we're looking for them to recognize
the difference between what they may
hear in the media versus what they hear
in the courtroom
and to promise us
that pursuant to that duty and that
responsibility that we all have towards
our true seeking process to the
presumption of innocence to the burden
of proof on the prosecution that they
will come into this case with an open
mind and not have any prejudgments about
the guilt of the accused
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney matthew mangino and terry
austin matthew what do you anticipate
are some of the difficulties in picking
a jury in a small county with such a
large case
well brian i think number one is
logistics i mean you're talking about an
unusual pool of jerk jurors 600 jurors
you know a thousand that received
uh juror requests so you're going to
have uh a logistical problem with regard
to where do these people stay certainly
with within uh the confines of kovid 19
how are we going to separate these
people so logistically there's going to
be a problem and then you're going to go
through this process of asking questions
that these jurors individually with
regard to what they know about this case
and whether they have made any uh
pre-determined decision based on what
they've learned so it's going to be an
arduous process to get through this pool
absolutely they anticipate one to maybe
even two weeks to go through that
process terry how has jury selection
been going so far and does that give you
any insight as to how long it could last
do you think it's going to last out two
weeks
i do think it's going to last that two
weeks that's what the judge actually
estimated and as you said there are so
many drawers to go through they're
taking that 600 putting them in a room
so that there's only 20 and they have
that distance apart but first the court
is going to ask the statutory questions
and then we will hear from the state and
the state will read its approved
questions and then you're going to hear
from the defense who's going to do the
same thing and by the time you get
through all of those jurors who are
rejected either because of cause or
rejected because they have a preemptory
challenge that's going to take some time
so far what we have heard though is some
of these jurors do feel negative against
the case so the real point is whether or
not they're going to be able to
be fair yeah got to try to find someone
neutral in this because like we said so
much media so much attention on this
case it's not about finding someone who
doesn't know about the case but someone
who could be fair and impartial as
you've always said in the past terry
thank you both now on to the federal
trial of elizabeth holmes where a family
friend turned theranos employee takes
the stand
daniel edlund was once college buddies
at duke university with elizabeth
holmes's brother christian he was later
hired by his friend's sister as a senior
product manager for theronos back in
2011. he was given crucial assignments
such as the company's walgreens
partnership and organizing tours of
headquarters for investors board members
and business partners evelyn was called
by prosecutors to testify about his role
in the company fight to times when he
was asked by holmes to make adjustments
for tours of hq that required hiding
certain areas of its research and
development lab from important visitors
he also said that partitions were
sometimes in place to hide areas where
theranos devices were located edlin also
said that he never gave a tour of the
clinical lab itself which is where the
patient samples were allegedly tested
holmes the former ceo of now defunct
company theranos faces 12 counts of
fraud for her time with the company
holmes claimed theron's would
revolutionize blood testing but later
tests found many problems with theranost
devices
still ahead on law and crime daily
former president trump files a lawsuit
to keep white house records a secret but
first alec murdoch appears in a south
carolina courtroom and lawn crime
daily's angelini brings us the latest
developments in the murdoch murder
mystery
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charged will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back disgrace south carolina
lawyer alec murdoch will remain behind
bars for now law and crimes angie levy
is here with what happened at murdoch's
bail hearing and what his lawyer has to
say about it angenette
brian the judge ordered alex murdock
held without bail at this time and he
said murdoch must undergo a psychiatric
evaluation before he will consider
setting bail for him again the judge
cited murdoch's uh opioid
addiction and the allegation that he
attempted to arrange his own death now
alec murdoch appeared in a richland
county courtroom this morning on charges
related to claims he kept 4.3 million
dollars from an insurance settlement for
the death of his housekeeper gloria
satterfield she died in 2018 in what was
described as a quote trip and fall
accident at murdoch's home but an
autopsy was never conducted today the
chief of the south carolina law
enforcement division said the cause of
satterfield's death is now being
investigated murdoch already faces
charges over an allegation he tried to
arrange his own suicide so his son could
collect 10 million dollars in life
insurance money and he's also a person
of interest in the murders of his wife
maggie and son paul back in june he was
arrested last week after leaving a rehab
center in florida the lawyers for both
sides spoke after the hearing
we knew it was going to be
an uphill battle
obviously uh the public interest and the
enormity of the accusations um but we're
glad that the judge is concerned about
his mental condition
um and we think we can get him a clean a
relatively clean bill of health by the
end of this week early next week from a
psychiatrist based on the six weeks of
examinations he's had by mental health
experts both at the detox center and the
rehab facility you know a lot of times
we say when a lawyer steals with a pen
it's just as bad as
somebody who steals with a gun we we
talked about that in the court there
today and a lot of times
it doesn't resonate but i actually
believe that it did resonate today
now the chief of sled said in court that
they are investigating a number of
allegations including the death of
gloria satterfield and also the death of
stephen smith in a hit and run there was
actually no mention from sled
in court when they were asked by the
judge about other open investigations so
there was no mention of the murders of
paul and maggie murdock in which alec
murdoch is a person of interest and when
asked murdoch's lawyers said after court
that his client had nothing to do with
the death of his wife and son
brian
thanks angeannette let's bring back
defense attorney math mangino and terry
austin to discuss the latest in the
murdoch murder mystery terry what does
it mean to be denied bond and could that
change for murdoch
well what it means is he will not be
released from jail he'll be held in
columbia south carolina and as angenette
said this is for the theft of those
settlement funds it's interesting to
note that the prosecution only asked for
bail in the amount of 200 000 and of
course the defense was asking that he'd
be releasing his own recognizance the
judge actually did say that he was
concerned about his mental health it
wasn't a notion of flight it was a
notion of he might be harmful to himself
and so the judge ordered this evaluation
now it could change the situation if in
fact this evaluation comes back and
finds that murdock is in good health and
mentally sound so we'll have to wait and
see what happens with that evaluation
now matthew is that somewhat shocking
that a former attorney would be denied
bond not high bomb but completely denied
bond partly because of his mental health
evaluation
well it is shocking whether it's a a
lawyer or not
everyone's entitled to bond
outside of a capital case uh so the fact
that there's no bond at all in this case
that this individual can't bond himself
up um is shocking uh you know you might
see in situations where there's a very
high bond which will ensure that
someone's getting in jail uh you know
pending trial but in this situation you
you have a judge who's talking about
somebody's mental health talking about
the fact that that he's a potential harm
to himself you know is the best place
for this person uh in jail if he's a
potential harm to himself i mean suicide
is certainly an issue uh within the
confines of local jails you know so i'm
surprised by the fact that bond was
denied and he was you know sent to jail
uh pending trial or pending a mental
health evaluation yeah as a public
defender for almost seven years now i've
never seen someone's mental health get
better in jail so that's an odd thing
for me to see and jeannette what about
the 4.3 million dollars from gloria
satterfield's death where's that money
well it's really interesting after court
eric bland one of the attorneys for the
satterfield family said that they've
actually gotten some of that money back
and he said we will get all of it back
so i don't know how he thinks they're
going to get it unless it's an account
somewhere or they think that alec
murdoch might have some of this money
just kind of laying around i don't know
but they are confident they said that
they will get that money for their
clients all right let's hope that
happens very soon thank you all coming
up on law and crime daily convicting
killer derek chovin to appeal his case
with a new attorney plus will former
trump advisor steve bannon be held in
contempt of court when the select
committee will make their vote next on
longtime
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
so-called january 6 committee is set to
vote tuesday night whether to hold
former white house adviser steve bannon
in contempt of court meanwhile former
president donald trump files a lawsuit
to prevent the committee from accessing
his records
all this is in relation to the capitol
riots that happened on january 6th as
law and crime daily reported the house
select committee in charge of
investigating the january 6 attacks
requested bannon provide details about
conversations he had with former
president donald trump they say those
conversations happened leading up to the
riots bannon refused to provide the
information and didn't show up after
being subpoenaed on monday former
president trump filed a lawsuit to stop
the january 6 committee from attaining
his records he says the requests are
unconstitutionally overbroad and violate
the separation of powers principles this
comes after president joe biden refused
to back trump's claim that the records
are protected by executive privilege
in response to former president trump's
lawsuit the committee issued a statement
saying in part quote the former
president's clear objection is to stop
the select committee from getting to the
facts about january 6 and his lawsuit is
nothing more than an attempt to delay
and obstruct our probe
let's bring back defense attorney
matthew mengino and co-host terry austin
terry do you see any strengths or merit
in the former president's lawsuit to
stop the subpoena from banning
i absolutely think this is a long shot
as far as this lawsuit is concerned the
committee is requesting these documents
and it is an executive privilege whether
or not they should be produced biden has
said he's not going to assert this
executive privilege and he cited the
fact that there is a public interest to
see these documents and frankly i think
that these white house records should be
released and that the privilege does not
apply to trump who is a former president
and not a current executive so
you know trump is claiming clearly that
there is no legislative purpose for this
that it's a fishing expedition but i
think that this privilege is something
that is reserved for the executive and
his argument will not prevail at the end
of the day
now matthew does congress have the power
to vote on contempt charges before the
lawsuit is decided and if they do how do
you think they'll rule
well i think that
the congress does have the ability to
vote on contempt before this lawsuit is
resolved the lawsuit is not in any way
uh aimed at uh you know
declaring some sort of injunctive relief
and i think it would be a
separation of powers issue if it was you
can't thumb your nose at congress uh if
congress issues a subpoena if they want
records if they want you to appear you
just can't ignore them and
and i think that the congress is going
to take action in this case because you
simply
cannot let someone uh just turn their
back and and refuse to comply uh with
the authority of the united states
congress it's a dangerous precedent to
do nothing here and i think congress
will act yeah that makes sense i think i
think that's the line there a dangerous
precedent for them not to act i think
they will do so just so other people
don't get a similar idea great point
matthew turning now to chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
whose weekly episode of brian ross
investigates focuses on a little-known
military scandal brian
thanks brian coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates a huge scandal
that most people have never heard of
involving the u.s navy
top admirals and a man by the name of
fat letter who used hookers and cash and
his own charm to win millions of dollars
in navy contracts across the pacific fat
leonard has pleaded guilty to corrupting
the u.s navy and creating a mafia-like
organization inside the navy partly
what's going on here is he believes
there's been a cover-up in the u.s navy
and a lot of the information that he
gave to investigators about admirals
that dealt with him wasn't acted upon in
his view and that's one of the reasons
that he talked that's coming up this
week on brian ross investigates on the
long crime trial network brian
thanks brian you can catch brian ross
investigates on tuesdays and thursdays
at 5 30 and 10 30 eastern time
when we come back derek chovin finds new
representation in court how private
attorneys stepped up to represent the
convicted murderer as he looks to appeal
his guilty verdict in the george floyd's
murder
[Music]
welcome back ex-minnesota police officer
and convicted killer derek shovin
acquires a new attorney after the
minnesota supreme court denied his
request for a public defender
back in 2020 derek showman was convicted
of second and third degree murder and
second-degree manslaughter for the
murder of george floyd he was sentenced
to more than 22 years in prison earlier
this month the minnesota supreme court
denied a public defender for the ex-cop
who plans to appeal his case shoving
said that he had no money and that his
debts greatly outweighed his assets this
left him to represent himself since he
wouldn't be able to cover attorney's
fees his attorney in the previous case
eric nelson was paid through the
minnesota police and peace officers
association legal defense fund in a
recent filing attorney william moram
stated that the law firm of moran
cardinal and erickson pa will appear for
sheriff on chauvin's behalf the
minneapolis police federation says they
are not paying for more man's
representation right now it's unclear
how chovan's newly hired team will be
compensated
matthew what does it mean that schoen
was denied a public defender after his
debts and assets were reviewed
especially since now he's hired an
attorney
well we all know uh brian that that um
we're a defendant is entitled to an
attorney but that doesn't mean he's
entitled to a free attorney if you have
the means to pay for an attorney then
you have to pay for your own counsel
only those who are indigent are entitled
to free representation uh so in this
case as in every case public defender's
office does an initial review they
determine if there's a asset that
there's sufficient assets or income they
refuse uh representation in this
situation that was done it was then
reviewed by the court and the court said
hey
you have the means to hire your own
attorney and you have to do that or
represent yourself
and see how that played out and as of
course some officers have a fund that
they pay into as they as they work and
that's how eric nelson was employed
derrick shoved obviously has a lot of
things on his plate that are taxing his
money no pun intended and that's why he
had to go this route terry what issues
do you think are likely to come up on
appeal
there are so many issues brian that are
going to come up on appeal they've
already talked about there was an abuse
of discretion by the court when there
was a failure to change the venue a
failure to sequester the jury for the
entire trial we know those are two big
issues they also tried to claim that
there was prosecutorial misconduct when
we had the closing arguments and you may
recall that the prosecution said the
defense was shading the truth and that
that was incorrect and wrong and
prosecutorial misconduct so there were a
number of other areas maurice hall also
wasn't allowed so i think that you're
going to see number of
appeal grounds absolutely and thank you
for joining us here on law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you